et tout cela au crible mais d'abord on
s'arrête sur la tête d'affiche
christophe castaner à l'intérieur il en
rêvait macron l'a fait on écoute le
nouveau ministre de l'intérieur c'était
lors de la passation de pouvoir tout à
l'heure au moment d'accepter cette
proposition
on s'interroge on s'interroge sur la
responsabilité qui est celle du ministre
de l'intérieur
on s'interroge sur la capacité à assumer
cette fonction
et très vite on se rassure on se rassure
parce que ce ministère est à la tête de
trois cent mille femmes sommes
totalement engagés sur sa capacité à
assumer cette fonction
un bon choix ben oui pourquoi pas c'est
de voir comment je peux me hisser à la
hauteur dont vous avez dit qu'elle
relevait plutôt d'un autre invité donc
c'est compliqué mais je pense que c'est
pas un mauvais choix parce que c'est un
élu de terrain et que c'est très
important particulièrement à ce
ministère de mettre un élu c'est un bon
choix parce que c'est pas idiot de
tenter un binôme avec un
un super flic entre guillemets et un
super politique puisque d'une certaine
manière qu as tu as l'air c'est quand
même un super politique je dire c c'est
une des grosses pointures socialiste qui
rejoint emmanuel macron il était très il
s'est fait il ya parfois dans des
conditions assez difficiles dans le sud
est donc pour toutes ces raisons là je
pense que c'est un assez bon choix
alexis un épouvantail facile pour la
droite christophe castaner ya plusieurs
façons d'analyser cette affaire de
casseneuil ailleurs comme quelque chose
d'assez 30 ans et qu'il fallait quinze
jours pour arriver à castaner qui était
quand même effectivement le choix non le
choix de la fidélité parce que le
premier la première raison pour à
présent avec dû choisir un médiateur
c'est ce qui me sera fidèle
est ce que je peux lui faire confiance
et de ce point de vue c'est de toute
évidence le meilleur choix et ses dires
pour ça que ce choix qui crevait les
yeux depuis ce but a fini par être fait
en dépit d'autres candidats qui ont été
poussés donc du poids de la fidélité la
question elle se poussent pas c'est
aujourd'hui le plus proche des manuels
macron donc devenu ça se défend
du point de vue du poids politique je
serai pas tout à fait d'accord et
qu'olivier à moitié d'accord c'est vrai
que c'est aujourd'hui c'est déjà énorme
jeu plein essor que je fais dans la
moitié mais c'est à dire que c'est vrai
que c'est au fond celui qui a le plus de
poids politique mais c'est pas du tout
un poids-lourd kastner c'est pas un
poids lourd socialiste qui est passé
chez makro c'était un poids moyen même
plutôt un poids léger socialiste mais le
fait est qu'aujourd'hui a si peu de
poids lourds et même si peu de poids
moyens chez emmanuel macron les poids
légers des garçons de d'hier sont
devenus les poids lourds c'est qui
malgré n'est pas poids lourds le devient
très honnêtement si vous regardez dans
les sondages dans la hiérarchie de la
popularité
il n'est pas du tout du tout du tout du
tout un poids lourd les poids lourds
s'étaient hulot les poids lourds
s'étaient colons les pc jamais était
castaner castaner les gens ne le
connaissent pas donc c'est pas du tout
un poids lourd une remontée certes elle
ensuite l'efficacité
on verra bien c'est un peu tôt pour le
dire lui n'y connais pas grand chose
c'est vrai qu'il a un adjoint entre
guillemets c'est exactement ça comme un
secrétaire d'état ou même dix délégués
qui connaît la faîtière des tâches sait
plus s'il est oui
il est secrétaire d'état il est même s
il est choisi secrétaire d'état c'est
juste un point intéressant
jusqu'à présent le musée l'intérieur
était de 0,8 à la hiérarchie ça dans le
lors de votes au collet de deux
travailleuses
deuxièmement au 11e rang qui ont de
tabac bah oui mais pourquoi c'est un
truc c'est très très bien c'est juste un
truc est moins prononcée sur justement
la figure de castanet reste un rallye
car je suis passé un handicap puisque de
toute façon les millé choix des menus
macro et depuis le départ d'avon enfin
depuis un an et le départ d'une des
poids lourds du modem d'avoir des des
ministres qui sont pas nécessairement
des poids lourds politiques
après dans le choix de christophe kasner
j'ai rejoins c'est ce que disait olivier
duhamel c'est dur je crois que dans la
peau de l'éventail des possibles
christophe castaner c'est un élu de
terrain qui connaît bien les électeurs
qui quand vous qui raconte comment il a
conquis sa et reconquis sa
circonscription en allant à pied marche
et rencontrer tous ces électeurs et
c'est quelqu'un qui est qu arrêter
d'avoir passé plusieurs mois à traverser
ça exactement et c'est quelqu'un qui est
et qui connaît qui mine de rien ça
connaît bien connais bien le sens mieux
l'opinion je pense qu'un certain nombre
de technocrates du gouvernement et pour
ça c'est important est que pour ça et sa
mission et probablement de faire le lien
avec les collectivités locales
ça relève de son ministère et c'est
quand même compliqué aujourd'hui ça
relève plus enlève de gestion des
réseaux et mai et il ya aussi la
préparation je croise il ne trompe pas
du retard d'un projet de redécoupage
électoral
ici les japonnais redécoupage électoral
ça c'est sûr
sur la question déjà que souvent les xi2
le manque de le nouveau monde qui trouve
un peu ses limites parce que il ya un
peu manque de oui-oui personnalité je ne
partage absolument pas l'analyse selon
laquelle c'est un poids lourd ou ce
serait une grosse pointure ou alors
elles ont vraiment réduit c'est c'est
pour les castaner il connaît les
électeurs parce qu'il en a pas
n'oublions pas qu'il était la tête de
liste socialiste aux élections
régionales paca qui a fait que la gauche
a dû avoir à choisir entre christian
estrosi et le front national ce qui fait
passer christian estrosi pour un homme
de gauche
alors c'était c'est un magicien de la
politique christophe castaner et puis
franchement que tête de liste originelle
était élu à forcalquier pour pierre de
lune mais non c'est pas des pulls des
huit députés c'est pas nous c'est
construit les sièges
non ce jour vivian kohl avaient été omis
de dire donc donc c'est non franchement
je trouve que alors plus le ridicule ne
tue pas un homme qui a dit qu'il était
quasiment amoureux des manuels macron au
début ça flagorneurs absolue c'est
quelqu'un qui n'a aucun nom je veux dire
je suis un peu étonné parce que qu'on
ait mis quinze jours à trouver
effectivement ce que disait qu'ils
brisent et la solution qui s'imposait
comme on a mis une semaine à trouver
françois de rugy qui lui s'est inscrit
dans la longue tradition des écologistes
qui de brice lalonde à nicolas hulot
sont toujours au même poste et les
trusts
c'est assez affligeant c'est à dire que
pas dire ça ne voulait pas dire en a mis
quinze jours
mais comme ici c'est comme si on avait
on s'était basés sur des attentes
c'est à dire et à la fin ça sera
castaner et à la fin c'est que si l'on
avait décidé comme ça a été fait
antérieurement pour hulot de se
contenter de remplacer poste pour poste
vous pourriez dire on a mis quinze jours
pour castanet soit parce que l'histoire
a écouté un exposé il ya les nouveaux
noms mais vous avez comme ça avec les
médias vous installez vous jetez un but
juste ma phrase vous avez un commentaire
dominant tout ça pour ça tout ça pour ça
et tout le monde un homme et répète le
même jour sans regarder un instant lui
et on va sur les routes y en a mais sur
quels sont les pensionnaires qui était
en charge des cultes aussi n'oublions
pas les déclarations grotesque qui
l'avait fait sur les femmes catholiques
qui était voilée
ça veut dire qu'il a oki aucune
connaissance non plus de ce dossier
l'avoir découverte de nos mères et voilà
c'est plutôt inquiétant c'est plus
inquiétant c'est quand même quelqu'un
donc pas monsieur pense que vous appelez
voilées des gens qui se contentent de
mettre un foulard est en effet une autre
est de tradition de mettre la foule a et
ça leur est encore parfois quand on va
la mettre sous la dent c'est pas dans la
rue excusez nous mais pas dans les
ardennes scolaire alors vous êtes sans
doute nombreux dans tout cas avoir
répondu à la question quand vous posez
êtes vous satisfait de la nomination de
christophe castaner au ministre au
ministère l'intérieur douzaine 5 peut
plus me fait monter la crème 72 pour ça
alors on l'a dit en face à christophe
castaner c'est un choix associés à leur
indignation l'a dit un spécialiste
patron du renseignement des dg assis les
autres maintenant on va on va aller à
passer un petit peu en revue si vous
voulez bien
justement je pense que c'était pas un
choix c'est qu'il n'avait plus le choix
c'est à dire que dans tous les noms
qu'ils ont la mise sous le nez il n'y
avait pas de personne qu'il avait
suffisamment confiance et donc on est
bien dedans c'est l'argument de la
confiance qu'ils ont bien évidemment
donc il n'a pas eu le choix c'était là
car forcés à laquelle il a fini par se
résoudre mais qui lui crever les yeux
depuis le début
papa la contradiction il ya deux minutes
c'est long mais toujours comme et de
l'intérieur le plus proche le plus loyal
et la décision forcée il n'avait pas le
choix mais c'est un peu contre les toits
mais parce qu'il a tenté autre chose
edouard philippe et anne et essayer de
lui vendre un coût d'un philippe va
tenter autre chose et c'est pas marrant
mais pourquoi ce rôle elle a mis quinze
jours mais pas que ça n'est pas que ça
d'une part et pour vous casser les
garder pour elle le savait il a pris les
médias comme aux riches mais la crise
l'a dit vous savez laisse avec enrouleur
il a joué avec avant on va dire leur
demain dimanche de demain non non on va
casser un peu plus et c'est tard il
apprend la lancer la machine médiatique
abonnés free la viande sa véranda gens
simplement les gens se disent à vannes
le fallu quinze jours pour cette fois
mais surtout cela aucune apporter non
mais il faut que ma non sélection plus
étrange dans la ville a mis quinze jours
tout le monde si on panique s'est
aggravée
c'est aussi un peu difficile bon
christophe castaner d'arrivée et et de
jouer le ministre qui est indispensable
alors qu'effectivement on a mis quinze
jours à trouver cette solution s'il
avait été si indispensable ça se serait
imposé l'équation politique vaut mon nom
8 c'est pas que castaner arrêté 8 mai à
londres où exactement le même profil que
pour celui de gérard collomb on a
l'impression qu'à l'intérieur il faut un
thuriféraire du président c'est un peu
dommage on en parle on l'a dit on va
aller regarder même avec un équilibre
alors sans doute on va commencer par
jacqueline gourault on en parle et qu'il
ya un périmètre élargi avec voilà
jacqueline gourault avec associé à deux
ministres l'un sébastien lecornu l'autre
julien normandie là c'est la prime du
modem la labérou comme tiago euros non
non non le leboutou renforcement quand
même 200 de son pib
je pense qu'effectivement il ya un côté
très politicien finalement très ancien
monde dans ce remaniement c'est qu'il
n'ya pas du tout de grands changements
on prend des fidèles du proche du
président et ont fait des petits
équilibré qu'un ou deux socialistes et
pas mal de proches de bayrou modem et
jacqueline go et l'idée derrière c'est
de se dire il faut se réconcilier avec
les collectivités les territoires mais
c'est pas bussereau non plus ne sais pas
y'a pas de voile ah bon
et là je pense que c'est très bien et
fait très bien l'affairé
mais c'est pas ça il va réconcilier avec
les territoires sur le fond là alexis a
raison sur le caractère tout simplement
politique de ce remaniement est en c'est
un monde où vraiment on peut importe si
et macro ont commencé à comprendre qu'il
faut aussi savoir faire de la politique
et donc donner satisfaction aux modèles
de l'éducation des gens qui viennent de
donner satisfaction à son camp et donner
satisfaction aux gens ouverts à droite
et ce qu'il a fait dans les quatre cas
de ce ministère c'est qu'ils commencent
à comprendre l'importance de la
politique ce qui est intéressant
là c'est la question des structures
gouvernementales vous avez deux types de
ministre quand on crée un gouvernement
vous aidez ceux qui veulent absolument
est très haut dans le protocole pour moi
c'est les crétins puisque ça n'a aucun
intérêt mais il se bat et s'ils sont
deux trois quatre cinq six ou bio
qu'avant ils sont las pavas nez comme un
paon et il se rase le matin avec
beaucoup de bonheur et puis vous avez
ceux qui se contrefichent de l'ordre
mais qui se bat sur l'esprit guerrier et
ça c'est autrement plus important est
donc le vrai changement là c'est le
changement des structures qui en effet
enlève à castanet enfin relève au
ministère de l'intérieur
la tutelle des collectivités locales des
relations avec les scolytes et de cannes
et dès demain ce ministère plein alors
on va voir ce que ça donne mais c'est
une tentative intéressante pour se dire
il faut que je structure autrement
l'action publique pour arriver à mieux
non seulement avoir des meilleures
relations avec eux mais à mieux faire
bouger les choses et roanne je vous
donne la parole quelques réactions juste
quelques instants joan baez ou suit 15
jours pour attendre ce remaniement était
ce nécessaire ça ça revient souvent
la fidélité d'accord auteurs pensent
comme les journalistes et pas qu est ce
que vous leur donnez pas l'excès alors
évidemment quand vous voulez qu'il fasse
à l'occasion d'un gala on commence alors
et vous dans vos propos c'est juste leur
blabla trop tous à l'alcool s'interroge
la fidélité d'accord mais les
compétences c'est plus léger on l'a dit
cette tendance entre
christophe castaner et laurent de nièces
le lui le encore que laurent ne s'est
pas vraiment un flic c'est un préfet
c'est un oui bon mais pas de trés
apprécié quand même d'abord canton mais
implique les gens ne sont pas contents
quand on met un gendarme ne sont pas
contents tant que magistrat un préfet
c'est en soi c'est pas absurde après ce
qu'il fera bien le boulot explique lato
sensu sais pas il attaque et malicieux
il a été préfet dans territoriales il a
il habitait de la police ahmad ezz un
service de police cette police est plus
difficile
laurent seigne matériaux fonctionnels
monsieur babineau denise castaner c'est
le choix de la sécurité et continue
castaner est un homme de confiance cela
démontre une certaine fébrilité
c'est trop tôt pour juger si c'est un
bon choix mais il a peu d'expérience et
toujours monsieur davino qui continue
j'aurais quand même préféré des nouveaux
visages et ça revient aux six essais des
troisièmes couteaux enfin tout le tout
ce qu'on évoque sur le côté finalement
il n'y avait pas non plus tonnes de nos
tant que personnalité qu'ils les gardent
secret d'un état chargé des relations
avec le parlement il n'a pas brillé
il n'a pas brillé lalart le parlement
n'a pas bien réussi à secondes et
l'action du gouvernement c'est pour ça
que se jouait à l'air très étonnant
parce que il aurait effectivement été un
très bon secrétaire d'état chargé des
relations avec le parlement il y avait
une logique dans cette ascension la
bombe je suis pas besoin de la rive 8me
premier ministre fort heureusement savez
question l'épopée joie vraiment un bon
moi je pense que la grande erreur
c'était de se brouiller avec valcke il
ya quelques mois macron à une étude mans
et 1000 valls qui du coup et leurs
colonies val j'aurais mis si entre temps
ne s'était pas brouiller valff
alors j'imagine l'émission maria
béguines bâle s'est brisé à 20,6 à
nouveau monde avec sergent
bah ouais non non pas du tout parce
qu'il avait plutôt un bon bilan l'atout
prendre le drian est d'ailleurs macro
comme essayer de décider le drian et
voudrions a pas voulu
je pense que le drian avait plus de
poids politique je dis pas que ça serait
un meilleur ministre l'intérieur cocasse
mais on ne sait pas encore mais en tout
cas en termes d'incarnation politique
qui pèse plus lourd que castaner bon et
le drian pas voulu donc rester castaner
qui lui a le grand grand mérite d'être
un fidèle des fidèles des fidèles voilà
au delà kastner cela sur le remaniement
moi je trouve ça montre un que macron se
contente mais c'était inventant de
consolider sa majorité parce que il va
pas chercher plus à droite va chercher
des gens de droite qui était déjà dans
sa majorité il va rechercher des modem
qui était part qu'il avait qu'il avait
lui-même fait sortir du gouvernement et
à un moment il va rechercher un peu de
socialistes qui sont des socialistes
savent être compatible avec lui donc il
a il a aujourd'hui consolide sa majorité
c'est important moi j'ai plutôt
l'impression que pour aller plus loin
dans les réformes mais il aurait fallu
qu'ils élargissent savas électorale donc
j'ai pas convaincu que ça change grand
chose là dessus
deuxième chose je trouve que c'est un
signe mais plutôt positive pour moi qui
revient sur des principes anciens qui
étaient des pas de politique mais plutôt
des techniques là clairement il allait
chercher il fait un remaniement qui est
politique et je pense que ce qui lui
manquait depuis un an et demi c'était la
politique
et deuxième chose il va rechercher des
centristes qu'ils avaient fait sortir
lui même nom qui revient sur ses
premières sur sa première philosophie de
conception au gouvernement en 2017 alors
on s'arrête encore sur quelques noms
s'ils voulaient bien donc on le sait
franck riester qu'un ministre de la
culture qui vient de la droite agir
constructive voilà mais c'est d'une
droite qui depuis le début soutient
emmanuel macron c'est pas une se dire ça
il élargit pas son assise électorale
n'était pas exactement dans la majorité
il a traité le tard mais les habitués
vont ils réagir
non mais il est lié à la verve de ce
groupe il était du côté de ce qui
s'était passé était plus proche donc
vraiment mais je veux dire c'est quand
même un tout petit chouia de plus de
récupération sur la droite et didier
guillaume qui remplace stéphane travert
à l'agriculture didier guillaume qui
vient du ps et valls east par
l'éloignement de manuel valls qui avait
annoncé en janvier qu'il a abandonné la
politique oui qui avait pris là je
voulais perdurer des groupes la coupe du
monde de rugby
et puis qui après un duo banon fût à
payer des québécois la normale je
regarde ce que j'ai entendu j'ai pas
vérifié mais se préparent les gens qui
font des trucs pas payé et puis alors en
jeu maintenant vous n'avez pas leurs 500
g ainsi il est revenu au sénat mais du
coup il n'a pas pu retourner au groupe
socialiste radical et puis parce que
voilà mais c'est sans doute ça compense
le départ de jacques mézard parce que
jacques mézard sénateur du cantal enfin
représenté un interlocuteur important
moi il me semble quand même que ce
remaniement ne permettra sans doute pas
à la réforme constitutionnelle de passer
moi je pense que maintenant
gérard larcher va vraiment faire du
sénat un lieu de d'obstacles à cette
réforme constitutionnelle pour ne pas
offrir cette victoire politique à macron
alors là mais si vous me présentez un
remaniement ministériel dans l'histoire
qui est servi à une révision
constitutionnelle pour qu'elle marche ça
n'existe pas mais je pense que par
rapport
le
un signe qui est envoyé en choisissant
didier guillaume et on remercie
méar donc on fait venir didier guillaume
c'est pour continuer à essayer d'avoir
au sénat où le groupe ar marc'h ne
représente quasiment rien enfin ces 25
sénateurs
non mais y aura besoin au moment de la
du vote de la réforme constitutionnelle
de cette majorité qualifiée
si le sénat il fait obstacle ça passera
pas mais on sait depuis donc il fera ou
cinq en tout cas certain nombre de long
qui connaissent la feu alors donc
entresol la réforme